[Music]
all right so we all have
a catalog of work uh depending on our
respective careers right joe you got a
lot of skits
you got a lot of you got last kids too
and on imda we
but i also have an illustrious film
career oh right right how many films how
many films
he's a movie right now she has
illustrious
some of them are on youtube yeah just
don't check imdb
ratings or anything oh that's all that's
a bunch of [ __ ]
no it is imdb are rotten tomatoes don't
look at it either of them
we're on imdb i'll back you up don't
believe imdb
because bd or dbd
it says that i came out on like [ __ ]
on all these other tv shows that i've
never once been in but apparently
they're in my profile so don't believe
it and you're born in san francisco i'm
born in san francisco and my
i'm one year younger than what i really
am that's right
you know what apparently i'm a
millionaire based off of the internet
yeah they think i have two million
dollars oh and i think i have like some
really vast collection of uh diplomas
and degrees
oh dude i want to have that
clearly thinks i'm smart i'm just
honored to be on something called
celebrity i'm like wow
yeah celebrities like celebrity
birthdays yes lovely birthdays
famous birthdays.com famous birthdays my
on-air co-host lucas's son
went and said did you know nikki is the
third most popular hawaiian in
the world and i was like wow who's the
first who they're like jason momoa and
the rock and i'm like duh
[ __ ] hey that's pretty you're in good
company but but then they also yeah but
how far
down the ladder but it was like this
they also said i mean i couldn't trust
it because they also got my birthday
wrong so i graduated from like some
really great universities like harvard
and i'm worth like five million dollars
what you're more than
but that's how you know it's a lie i was
like first off who the hell is gassing
them up because bring it on
i'm like yes i'm going to need you a
reference there was this other website
that i recently
found and i forgot what it is but it
pretty much had a list of everything
that i had
almost ever said on video
about my life about the way i grew up
about like just my past
and about i forgot the percentage but a
high percentage of it was correct but
also
a high percentage of it was incorrect
but i'm like well that's so crazy that
they really paid attention to everything
i said on video
not mine half of the [ __ ] is lies for me
all my
i think you know when i found my pokemon
card collection recently
oh yeah it said that it was worth many
thousands of dollars
but i can't find anyone to buy it it's
hot right now though
no i know but i can't find anyone to buy
it so i think that you're worth
even more than five million but who will
pay right is is up in the air
sorry for according to celebrity net
worth i'm poorer than you so i'm the
rich one in the relationship
i'm worth two million dollars i can't
afford two benefits off of you
yeah oh yeah listen i had i had two
options to drink from i'm like on that
one i'm gonna take this one
amen all right so back to uh
our body of works how would you feel
work
[Music]
how would you feel if you would lose all
the rights
to your body of work well i mean didn't
that happen to the beatles
or like a lot of musicians in the past
yeah didn't mj buy paul mccartney's
songs and all that oh [ __ ] yeah
that's not shocking because well because
a lot of people in the music industry
get [ __ ] that way well most people
don't even know how the music industry
works you're very right because there
are distribution companies or people
that own the rights of the song that you
need publishing
you also have whoever wrote the song can
take credit for certain things if you
don't handle your paperwork correctly
and then you have um record labels
distribution labels
publishing sometimes you can't pay for
studio time so you pay for an equity of
your song and then your song gets taken
out
all kinds of [ __ ] it is a shady business
and they don't really even own their
names unless they have a good lawyer
right isn't kanye west currently in a
in a like battle this is crazy i mean my
lawyer actually he also has a rec
but he also is a part of the problem
because he has his own record good music
dude britney spears is [ __ ]
controlled by her own estate that her
father runs
yes my lawyer made a career out of
getting old artists like sly in a family
stone and then even like master p and
yeah
he he he basically made a career out of
um
fighting for the little guy who got
[ __ ] over by the uh studios yeah
and so he came up really hard just
going back after [ __ ] up contracts
yeah
because companies like to send you
[ __ ] up contracts that
they think you won't read so because
you're excited you're excited
so you will sign away your rights
because they write things that say
section 16. like you will not have a
lawyer or a third party look over this
section and if you do
we will charge you we will charge you
for every violation
and if we decide to sue you
that's why we talk about corporatism
because it's a [ __ ] nightmare so
that's why
the music industry is filled with a lot
of eager individuals who are willing to
sign for the immediate check and they do
take advantage the same with modeling
industry entertainment
uh so on and so forth i mean it's really
a lot uh
that's why people make lots of money off
of reading contracts and
um trying to revise contracts and help
people get out of
really masturbating and making contracts
as complicated as possible yes so that
only
certain people can read you have to
understand latin to [ __ ]
and the way that they reference things
that don't exist in the paperwork that's
given to you
an artist and most people that if you
have the option to have someone help you
yo that's why managers go and uh totally
wreck most people's careers because of
the paperwork they signed yo if i'm like
cool you're gonna take care of my career
you're only gonna take a center
percentage
yeah but you have like six jobs for me
now cool let's get rid of this let's do
this now
six is done and he's like by the way
that you know that piece of paper you
sign i
own everything you've done and the
residual on it
and your name and you cannot go and work
anywhere and i'm skimming off the top
and i'm i'm literally stealing from you
and there's not much you can do about it
basically 99 of your money oh yes and
since you signed this piece of paper
legally i'm right you're wrong that's
how the world works
well that's the music industry in most
of entertainment in the world of
art do we know banksy yeah yeah
love banks what is he famous for being
anonymous but also the i was like
anonymous i was like his stencils
shredding one is the best one the
shredding one the one where he
got sold he bought it and he shredded
immediately he's famous for being an
anonymous
street artist he's anonymous and that is
the problem that is the core of the
story here so
basically he banksy may lose the rights
to his work if he continues to stay
anonymous
after losing a legal battle with the
card company wanting to use his images
what so the fact that he stays anonymous
is gonna be the result of his downfall
as an artist
when we find out who he is is so boring
but exactly so it's like now they're
really
pitching him against the wall now it's
like hey come out with your real
identity also
so you can retain the rights of course
is the bank see a girl's name or a guy
yeah exactly who knows what if it's a
woman
saying like wait wait i don't want to
come out and i got to be anonymous
because then everyone gets to think i'm
a man and then i get to
just like with jk rowling like a like a
ghost like
i did to be like very androgynous
yeah whatever what jesus was a man
and get by get over it too i'm not over
it steve
i have to keep up fighting a fight
yeah i don't know you're you could be
right that's a ghost rider that would be
the ultimate like reveal if banksy ends
up being a girl
and not only a girl it's a grandma with
no teeth
invisalign oh no she doesn't need
invisalign no no
invisalign it's dentures no teeth that's
right she sucks dick better than the
individual yeah she's got one up on you
i definitely started drinking the
alcohol during this one i was like we're
getting somewhere
let's go there let's go there wait so
what card company
uh the card company is bicycle i do not
know
but how are they gonna bully how are
they is there another one to play
is there any other well what do they
gain out of him or her
exposing their identity what's what's
the well i think the
idea they get to use these designs for
free because
yeah so they want the rights to use his
artwork to print now
so like it's famous okay it's like mona
lisa why wouldn't you want to use the
mona lisa so he doesn't have any
but let's so he doesn't have any
copyrights or any trademarks on any of
the stuff he does because he can't put a
legal there's no legal name
wait so he kind of like is really
screwing himself with that
exactly kind of but we don't know how
banksy makes his his or her money
uh but but i love that i inserted that
it's just now we have to say his or her
constantly um but
you guys remember the south park episode
so a couple years ago
the washington redskins formerly named
washington ritz because now they're the
washington football team oh they
actually changed it i thought they were
so
hard on we will never do that on the
washington football team okay
wait there's no name there's no name
they're called the washington football
team there's no mascot
there's no mascots it's the big like
yellow w the yellow w
okay so they lost their they should be
the washington salmons
but go ahead they lost the trademarks
three years ago i think four years ago
and so at the time south park did a
hilarious episode where cartman
he started a company and just named it
the washington redskins
and then dan snyder like comes in the
room and he's like
hey don't you know you can't call this
[ __ ] the washington redskins and carter
was like
why not like i [ __ ] i had the company
[ __ ] you and then he's like
because it offends us and then the guy
behind him who's like the coach of the
redskins at the time he's like he's like
you're making a [ __ ] joke out of our
name and like that that's the whole idea
though is that
it's offensive because to the natives
yeah right exactly
but now he's doing it today they're
using the native like brand to make
money obviously
to get this out for sports but but
that's basically what this is too it's
the same exact idea
that's sure there's they're completely
screwing them over and
uh is uh the representative from the
banksy
like are they coming out against it at
all because he is anti-corporatist too
yeah yeah yeah basically so banksy for
the past two years
has actually been in a legal battle for
one particular
uh painting of his called the flower
thrower and i'll show you that
oh yeah the guy with the uh bouquet
that's yeah you're gonna throw it yeah
one of his most famous ones so this is
uh uh like uh like a protester throwing
something
possibly a molotov cocktail but you
replaced it with uh some flowers
yeah and that's become an iconic
painting of his and now he's lost the
rights to this specifically
the rights to that to a card company
yeah so the car company has the rights
to print this and
banksy makes zero why because they
trademarked it before he could
uh i think it's because it's a public
thing like he put it outside
yeah yeah it's not his property it's
it's a public yeah that's what i mean by
how do you trademark graffiti in the
first place
yeah i think i think that the loophole
then would be that for him to come out
as
as a person now but you would
have to if your piece of art or your
image or whatever you still have to go
through the process to say
it's mine so even if he does come out
that doesn't mean that that's still his
painting he didn't sign it it's no
longer i mean but it's no longer
i know that's super messed up
business-wise i don't think it's any
it's not his anymore
yeah even if he does come out because
now the card company owns it like if i
say
this is my name and somebody's like well
i technically bought your name
online before you did so it's my name
yeah they like parking
the urls and [ __ ] yeah so even though it
is my name but somebody else owns it
that's yours you paid for it that's the
whole dilemma of these like underground
artists right
is like they get famous and then they
want to make a business
out of what it doesn't go against of
what they're standing for in the first
place it's like
we're underground we're doing this and
then like you actually start
making money off of it and then now you
go and be the ones that you were
trolling you're part of the problem what
he
should do is yeah what should he do i
don't i don't think
that he should come out if you are a
true artist protect your
your art as far as who you are what you
represent
the principle because if that company
goes and takes it as an artist you sit
back and you go
we know that corporate america went and
stole and [ __ ] the system now let me
go create more art
right in protest to what they're doing i
hope that's what they end up deciding
because okay take the image that's cool
he's ju
he's an artist he makes the product he
can keep coming out with more work this
is a drop
that's a [ __ ] drop in the bucket for
him if he really is about his shoes not
to brag too hard but i'm about
two away from banksy uh and so
i have an illustrious film career
as an artist my point is that uh i don't
have a point i just want to say that no
no
but banksy basie should not do anything
banksy should just
chill and banksy if banksy came out was
like i'm banksy i want to get my money
that's the most anti-banksy thing
banksy won't do that i don't even have
to worry about it what do you think but
maybe he can't pay rent this month so
he's going to be like
he has like he has a lot of what are
they called like patreon
uh that that one yeah benefactors like
or people that represents what
they're patriots yeah he has a whole
paycheck like there's people that
represent his
his brand or his estate and that's how
they're able to make he's a lawyer for
[ __ ] sake
we all know like we know he has someone
else
the credit card company money is like
that ain't [ __ ] in the long run because
he can lose so much by exposing himself
this [ __ ] will be like deep throat
though where we're all like oh my god
who's deep throat
for a long time they thought it was
george h.w bush they thought it was like
colin powell
and [ __ ] deep throat was the informant
for the watergate scandal oh
this guy named w mark felt was deep
throat how boring
fbi associated director might be thrown
better so it's way better to not
reveal yourself what do we find out that
banksy is not even one person it's like
a crew people that's one
idea yeah some people welcome to what is
bitcoin
and where does it go where does it go
where does it come from
nobody knows nobody knows and that's the
thing and that's probably a big part of
his
it is his brand let's be real these are
stencils
art is subjective we also know the
benefit of buying art we know that how
the art market works
that they overprice certain things to
get tax cuts it's all one big thing
looped in together
he will lose his money if he exposes
himself because what
if he or she is just
regular what or what if they're like
obama or something
like some crazy-ass like figure but i
feel like everyone's always
disappointed we're in love with the idea
that's the same the mystery's way back
you know what i mean we're in love with
the idea of never knowing this man come
this person comes in
it's whoever i want it to be in your
mind banksy is a woman that is defying
all odds that is going out and doing
this
and then the writers of south park have
secretly been hiding
behind this the whole [ __ ] time but
we all know it'd be trey not matt i mean
no offense but but that's the beautiful
[ __ ] part of art
is that it's whatever i decide i want it
to be
imagine you read a headline tomorrow
banksy is albert manchester from
whatever
it's like suck off sucks it's a
toothless grandma but imagine that
really is his name
and then you just predicted it that'd be
[ __ ] crazy
i i i i actually know who he is he has
an illustrious
acting career right
bye